syphilis like the black death and
smallpox has earned its place in history
as a burden on mankind syphilis gained
its notoriety for its horrifying three
stages and caused its victims to go
insane a symptom that famously Afflicted
Frederick Nietzsche and Al Capone with
advances in Immunology syphilis no
longer poses a threat and is easily
treated worldwide there are six million
syphilis cases reported every year and
most are cured with a simple
prescription of penicillin however it's
worth knowing something about a disease
that ravaged Europe for 500 years caused
gruesome disfigurations and made its
victims go insane this is the dark
science of syphilis
foreign
[Music]
was first recorded in mid-15th century
Europe it was most common among
prostitutes and Johns making The
Afflicted associated with immorality and
shame it spread to North America in the
late 15th century by European Navigators
who were exploring the new world
syphilis is caused by the bacterium
treponemopolitum or t pallidum a
spirochete bacteria its body is not
spherical or rod-shaped but rather
shaped like a corkscrew which helps it
to infect its host
unlike other bacteria it's not found in
nature samples of soil water and even
feces are a void of its presence this is
because t-peladum is a sensitive
bacteria that requires very specific
conditions to live if left on a Surface
T pallidum can only live for about two
hours in contrast E coli a bacteria
found in the human gut can live on a
surface for several days even in a lab
tea palatum is nearly impossible to
culture the only environment where T
pelidum is able to live is the human
body since humans are the only Reservoir
that keeps tea palatum alive humans are
the cause of the bacteria sticking
around for over 500 years T pallidum is
not spread through air droplets like the
common cold or even regular contact on
the skin due to its sensitive living
conditions it has to be spread via
intimate contact on a specific surface
of the body in this case intimate
contact is defined as kissing or sexual
activity where mucosal surfaces such as
in the mouth or genitals make physical
contact
the transfer happens when an individual
with a syphilitic Legion touches a
mucosal surface or break in the skin
once on the surface tea palatum excretes
an enzyme called Matrix metano
proteinase 1 or mpp1 which breaks down a
protein called collagen making it easier
to burrow into the soft tissue mucosal
or broken skin is required for transfer
of syphilis as this tissue is soft very
thin and has less surface protection
making it easier to grow into regular
unbroken skin or epidermis is hard for t
palatum to grow into since it's thicker
rougher and has acidic oils on the
surface that damage the bacteria once T
pallidum is in the body the immune
system mounts a response like it would
with any bacterial infection by inducing
fever and inflammation then after a
couple of days the immune response stops
and the body goes back to normal the
immune system thinks T pallidum is gone
but it's not it's just invisible
t-palder manages to hide from the immune
system because part way through the
infection it shuffle a single Gene in
its DNA thereby changing the sequence of
proteins on its surface with different
surface proteins antibodies and immune
cells are unable to recognize the
bacteria permitting T pallidum to
replicate over several weeks the first
stage of Syphilis is called primary
syphilis and appears about three weeks
after the initial infection painless
lesions called shankers appear at the
site where the bacteria entered the body
lesions most often appear on the
genitals or mouth where there is thin
moist mucosal tissue or where there is a
break in the skin these lesions contain
hundreds of colonies of bacteria and are
highly infectious if touched shankers
heal within three to four weeks and
after the primary infection T pallidum
Alters its DNA and starts to evade the
immune system in between the first and
second stages of syphilis T pelidum
aggressively replicates throughout the
body but is only able to do so every 30
hours which compared to other bacteria
is very slow E coli for example
replicates about every 20 minutes this
slow replication rate is not a weakness
but rather an advantage for T palatum
due to its very slow replication T
palada maintains a low concentration
below the critical antigen Mass the
critical antigen mass is the threshold
for the number of antigens from bacteria
or viruses that must be present to
elicit a response since T palatum
replicates at such a slow rate it's able
to stay below the critical threshold and
avoid being seen by the immune system
thereby allowing it to spread throughout
the body three to six weeks after the
initial infection t-peladum has had time
to replicate moving on to the second
stage secondary syphilis secondary
syphilis is much different and more
intense than primary syphilis primary
syphilis was just a painless lesion at
the site of contact in secondary
syphilis lesions appear on the arms
hands feet chest and back unlike primary
syphilis these lesions are extremely
painful and highly infectious as they
Harbor the treponema bacteria other
symptoms include fever enlarged lymph
nodes hair and weight loss after about
four weeks the secondary phase resolves
in t palatum enters a prolonged Dorman
phase where it remains inactive for as
long as 15 years after secondary
syphilis the worst appears to be over
there's an absence of symptoms for
several years and health is not
seriously affected by the dormancy yet T
pelladum is waiting in the shadows to
inflict its worst damage in the third
stage between 10 and 20 years after the
initial infection T pallidum reactivates
initiating tertiary syphilis the final
and most destructive phase once
reactivated the bacteria in facts in
highly specific area of the body walls
of blood vessels infection of the
vasculature or blood vessels causes
chronic inflammation which appears as
large growths of inflamed scar tissue
called gamas gummas range in size and
grow in soft tissue causing gruesome
disfigurements if they grow large enough
infection of the blood vessels causes
twofold damage to the body the blood
vessel itself and the organs that
receive blood from the vessel are both
affected inflammation in blood vessels
causes calcification or the buildup of
calcium in the walls of the vessel
calcification makes blood vessels narrow
and reduces blood flow meaning less
oxygen and nutrients are getting to the
organs two systems in the body that are
dramatically affected by this are the
cardiovascular and central nervous
systems the cardiovascular system in
particular is affected by T pallidum
because it infects the walls of the
thoracic aorta the largest artery in the
body the thoracic aorta extends from the
heart through the chest and into the
abdomen and carries a significant amount
of blood like other blood vessels the
thoracic aorta undergoes calcification
in this vessel walls reducing blood flow
in the largest artery in the body
calcification also affects the aortic
valve which controls blood flow into the
heart calcification around the valve
makes the valve stiff and is not fully
open thereby reducing blood flow into
the heart itself additionally due to the
chronic inflammation the thoracic aorta
becomes engorged with fluid known as an
aortic aneurysm all of these effects
reduce the heart's performance causing
palpitations fatigue cardiac infarction
and even heart failure the central
nervous system is also damaged by
vascular inflammation owing to the
symptoms of insanity nerve cells have a
very low tolerance for hypoxia or lack
of oxygen even a small reduction in
oxygen can damage or even kill neurons
as nerve cells receive less nutrition
signaling between neurons become
sporadic causing partial paralysis and
motor functions most notable in the
limbs and eyes regions of the brain such
as the amygdala and prefrontal cortex
which deal with emotional regulation and
logic start to deteriorate this affects
sensory memory and interpretive
functions manifesting as personality
changes memory impairment hyperactive
reflexes and hallucinations in the past
these effects were misdiagnosed as
insanity but in reality is the brain
gradually malfunctioning from decreased
nutrition as tertiary syphilis
progresses damage to the vasculature
gets worse and the central nervous
system deteriorates further nerves
associated with touch sensation degrade
to where the arm's hands and feet cannot
be consciously felt paralysis of the
muscle becomes so severe that standing
or walking is no longer possible death
eventually occurs from either heart
failure or neurological complications
from the first day of infection to death
syphilis can be as short as 10 years or
as long as 30 years today syphilis is
not something to be concerned about as
it's easily treated with antibiotics
victims in the past who suffered from
these Dreadful stages suffered because
they went untreated for their entire
life with modern medicine and treatments
this rarely ever ever happens
sometimes science can be seen as
difficult foreign and even boring yet
there are times when science grabs our
attention and draws Us in yearning for
more answers often what draws us Center
topics that are dark Macabre or
terrifying it's with the intention of
this video that you too were drawn in
and sought to have your questions
answered thanks for watching Dark
science
[Music]